This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。人类出品，如假包换。2%。这就是当电梯旁有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是两个数字“2”。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我要成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他罪有应得。我们总说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回首当年》播客。对 1979 年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首当年》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《难走的路》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知晓自己在做什么的专业执照人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界传递着这样一个信号：你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《难走的路》。
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. So this episode today, it was inspired by an article I saw the other day, essentially commemorating the five years since the beginning of the COVID-19 pandemic. And the article was basically a series of photos from that time. Pretty fascinating. But what was really, really interesting and what really inspired me so much were people's reactions to this article.
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析我们二十多岁的心理。所以今天的这一期节目，灵感来自于我前几天看到的一篇文章，这篇文章基本上是为了纪念新冠疫情爆发五周年。而这篇文章基本上就是当时的一系列照片。相当迷人。但真正非常、非常有趣，并且真正给我带来巨大启发的是人们对这篇文章的反应。
because it was honestly such a full spectrum of grief, confusion, frustration, but specifically a lot of people who were, quite frankly, shocked that it had been so long since COVID had begun because a lot of them reported, a lot of them were saying, they felt kind of frozen in time at the start of 2020. And those five years didn't feel like the typical five years. years that we would actively experience. It's this weird sense that, yes, life has moved on. We are no longer in an active pandemic, but it feels like a distinct before and after, before COVID and after COVID. And a lot of us inevitably missed out on experiences, missed out on opportunities
因为老实说，那真是悲伤、困惑、沮丧的全光谱，但具体来说，有很多人，坦白说，他们对新冠爆发至今已经过去这么久感到震惊，因为他们中的很多人报告说，很多人都在说，他们感觉自己在 2020 年初的时间里仿佛被冻结了。这五年感觉并不像我们平时积极经历的那五年。这是一种奇怪的感觉，是的，生活已经继续。我们不再处于活跃的疫情中，但感觉有一个截然不同的“之前”和“之后”，新冠之前和新冠之后。我们很多人不可避免地错过了经历，错过了机会
and time because of that chapter. And to this day, we still feel like we haven't really caught up or made up for the experiences and milestones we skipped over because of those years. And that reaction, that reaction to the big five years since the pandemic is one I really want to examine today because many, many of my fellow 20-somethings have been in my DMs with questions about this idea of the pandemic skip. Feeling as if we have missed out on so much and are we ever going to be able to make up for that lost time, or will it just forever be a chapter in our lives that we have to grieve? We in society at large, I think we talk a lot about the long-term consequences of COVID, and we talk about it in terms of the loss of precious lives and the children
由于那个章节，我们错失了时间和机遇。直到今天，我们仍然觉得自己还没有真正赶上，也没有弥补因为那些年而跳过的经历和里程碑。而这种反应，对疫情爆发五周年的这种反应，正是我今天非常想探讨的，因为我的许多、许多二十多岁的同龄人都通过私信问我关于“疫情跳过”这个概念的问题。感觉我们错过了太多，我们还能弥补那些失去的时间吗，还是说这永远只是我们生活中必须为之悲伤的一个章节？我认为，我们整个社会在很大程度上都在谈论新冠的长期后果，我们谈论的是宝贵生命的逝去以及孩子们
falling behind in school and the lingering economic impact. All of those are really significant and important, but what we don't consider is the everyday impact of feeling like time has stood still and that we are still behind, especially for people in our 20s because this time is so sacred and we are constantly being told, these are like the best years of your life, like don't waste them, don't blink or they'll be over. But, you know, that time was taken from us, even though it wasn't our choice and we're still trying to adjust. You know, not to sound dramatic, but we did undergo a collective trauma. COVID was a collective trauma.
落后于学校进度以及挥之不去的经济影响。所有这些都非常重大且重要，但我们没有考虑到的是，感觉时间静止、我们依然落后的日常影响，特别是对于我们二十多岁的人来说，因为这段时间是如此神圣，我们经常被告知，这些就像是你生命中最美好的几年，不要浪费它们，不要眨眼，否则它们就结束了。但是，你知道，那段时光被从我们身边夺走了，尽管这不是我们的选择，我们仍在努力适应。你知道，听起来可能有点夸张，但我们确实经历了一场集体创伤。新冠是一场集体创伤。
And many of us between the ages of 18 to 34 experience that very differently from other groups and other, I guess, age brackets in the population. So what are the consequences of that been for our social development, our emotional development, also just our general sense of life satisfaction, but also how do we overcome this sense of bitterness, maybe resentment, indignation, sadness over the time, the experiences, the opportunities that we lost. This is really what I want to discuss today.
我们当中许多 18 到 34 岁之间的人，与人口中的其他群体和其他年龄段相比，对它的体验截然不同。那么，这对我们的社会发展、情感发展以及我们对生活满意度的整体感受，究竟产生了什么后果呢？同时，我们该如何克服这种对我们失去的时间、经历和机遇的苦涩、怨恨、愤慨和悲伤感？这正是我想在今天讨论的内容。
We can acknowledge the past. We can say this was just awful that this happened, but what next? How do we overcome that? So without further ado, my lovely, lovely listeners, let's talk about the psychology of the pandemic skip. So the pandemic skip, this concept, it refers to this sense that our mental age is a lot younger than our chronological age because the pandemic has caused us to miss out on very important life experiences that were essential for our development. So essentially, we feel frozen in time and we feel like our development is delayed. So you might be 27, but you still feel 23 or 24, which in our 20s is actually quite a huge jump.
我们可以承认过去。我们可以说发生这种事简直太糟糕了，但接下来呢？我们如何克服这一点？废话不多说，我可爱的听众们，让我们来聊聊“疫情跳过”背后的心理学。所以，“疫情跳过”这个概念，指的是这样一种感觉：我们的心理年龄比实际生理年龄年轻得多，因为疫情导致我们错过了对我们发展至关重要的重要生活经历。因此，从本质上讲，我们感觉时间被冻结了，我们的发育似乎也延缓了。所以你可能 27 岁，但你感觉自己还是 23 或 24 岁，而在我们的二十多岁，这其实是一个相当大的跨度。
You know, even if in the grand scheme of things, three years is not that large. In our 20s, you know, I know people who are now married at 27 who had not even met their partner at 23. we can have entirely different jobs, live in entirely different places, have entirely new friends. I really do believe that a year in our 20s is five years any other time. And that really goes to show, it's just think how much could change and maybe should have changed during that period of the pandemic where we were in lockdown, we couldn't travel, just we were experiencing a global emergency. So pandemic skip, pandemic pause, it's all the same thing.
你知道，即使从宏观角度来看，三年并不是那么长。但在我们的二十多岁，你知道，我认识的人里，现在 27 岁已经结婚了，而他们在 23 岁时甚至还没遇到自己的伴侣。我们完全可以从事不同的工作，住在完全不同的地方，结交全新的一友。我真的坚信，二十多岁时的一年相当于其他任何时期的五年。这确实表明，只要想一想，在疫情期间，我们处于封锁状态，无法旅行，仅仅是在经历一场全球紧急事件的那段时期里，有多少事情发生了改变，或许又本该发生改变。所以，“疫情跳过”、“疫情暂停”，其实都是一回事。
Essentially, there was this isolation and almost break from reality caused by COVID that has resulted in a lot of long-term developmental shifts and also grief, grief for many of us. So why does this happen? Why do we feel frozen in time? What's the long-term reaction to this? Well, I have three psychological explanations for why you feel like you cannot move on from these years and you feel like you cannot move on from the lost time. The first is that traumatic experiences tend to give us a warped sense of time. Now, the COVID pandemic and the ensuing lockdowns,
本质上，新冠造成了一种孤立感，几乎是对现实的脱节，这导致了许多长期的发育转变，也带来了悲伤，对我们许多人来说是悲伤。那么，为什么会这样？为什么我们会感觉时间被冻结了？对此的长期反应是什么？嗯，对于为什么你觉得无法从这些年份中走出来、觉得无法摆脱失去的时间，我有三个心理学解释。首先是，创伤性体验往往会给我们一种扭曲的时间感。现在，新冠疫情以及随之而来的封锁，
that wasn't just 30 seconds of trauma. That wasn't even a few days of trauma or even a few months. It was for some people years, years of going through something where every single day you had no idea what was happening. Case numbers were rising. You had no idea, you know, what the government was going to say you needed to do. If toilet people was going to run out, you know, if you would be able to see your friends, that is traumatic because it is so deeply uncertain and threatens our core sense of security. There was one study done during that time that surveyed thousands of Americans in the first six months of the pandemic, and they found that for a lot of them, time felt like it had either sped up or slowed down. This cognitive reaction, this warped sense of time, is actually quite
那不仅仅是 30 秒的创伤。那甚至不是几天或几个月的创伤。对某些人来说，那是几年，是连续几年经历这样一种情况：每一天你都不知道发生了什么。病例数在上升。你根本不知道政府会说你需要做什么。人们会不会把厕纸抢光，你能不能见到你的朋友，这都是创伤性的，因为它是如此高度的不确定，并威胁到我们安全感的核心。当时曾做过一项研究，在疫情头六个月调查了数千名美国人，他们发现对许多人来说，时间感觉要么加速了，要么减速了。这种认知反应，这种扭曲的时间感，其实相当
common after some kind of unprecedented collective trauma, like a natural disaster or a global pandemic. So the pandemic also had the effect of really stripping away external markers of time. So things like birthday celebrations, you know, a lot of them took place over Zoom that didn't feel as important. Job transitions, life transitions, like moving from graduate into your first full-time job, commutes, social events, all things that would give us a sense that time was passing. They disappeared. And that has led to what some psychologists will now call the Groundhog Day effect. Groundhog Day after the very famous movie with Bill Murray, where his day just feels like it's repeating and repeating and repeating, something that I think a lot of us experienced during
在经历了某种前所未有的集体创伤（如自然灾害或全球大流行）之后，这是很常见的。因此，疫情还有一个效果，就是真正剥夺了时间的外部标记。比如生日庆祝活动，你知道，很多都是通过 Zoom 进行的，感觉没那么重要了。工作转型，生活转型，比如从毕业步入第一份全职工作，通勤，社交活动，所有这些能让我们感受到时间流逝的事物。它们都消失了。这导致了一些心理学家现在所称的“土拨鼠日效应”。“土拨鼠日”源于比尔·默瑞的那部著名电影，在片中，他的一天仿佛在不断地重复、重复、再重复，我认为这是我们在许多人身上都经历过的一种现象
the pandemic. So without the usual kind of milestones to differentiate days, weeks, and months, time became a blur. And many people, if they're asked to recall an event, and I say that happened in 2020, 2021 or 2022, they don't know. It's just one big. lump of years to us with no events, situations, ways to distinguish. There was also this interesting interaction that some researchers are pointing to in our age group of people experiencing accelerated aging but stunted growth. So a lot of us might feel like we actually aged faster during the pandemic because of stress and uncertainty, having to skip important milestones and just enter the next chapter unprepared. That's leading to, you know, a sense that we've aged faster,
大流行期间。因此，如果没有通常用来区分日、周、月的里程碑，时间就变成了一片模糊。许多人如果被要求回忆一个事件，我说那是发生在 2020、2021 或 2022 年，他们根本不知道。对我们来说，它只是一个巨大的、没有任何事件、情况或区分方式的年份大杂烩。一些研究人员还指出了我们这个年龄段人群中一个有趣的交互现象，即经历了“加速衰老但发育停滞”。因此，由于压力和不确定性，我们许多人可能觉得自己在疫情期间衰老得更快了，不得不跳过重要的里程碑，毫无准备地进入下一个篇章。这导致了一种感觉，即我们变老得更快了，
but then on the other side, we also feel like we have paused our personal growth. So we are back to living with our parents. We were stuck in stagnant jobs, stagnant relationships because we had nowhere else to go. And that duality has created. created an unsettling experience of being both too young and too old for where you are in life. You feel like, oh, you know, I'm too old to be going out partying all the time, but also I still feel young enough to be doing those things because I missed out previously. So there's another term for this. It's called Arrested Development, not the TV show, although what a brilliant TV show,
但在另一方面，我们又觉得自己的个人成长停滞了。所以我们回到了跟父母同住的生活。我们被困在停滞不这种状态里，工作停滞，关系停滞，因为我们无处可去。这种二元性创造了一种令人不安的体验，即对于你当前的生活阶段来说，你既显得太老，又显得太年轻。你觉得，哦，你知道，我都这把年纪了，不适合整天出去开派对，但同时我又觉得自己还年轻，完全可以做那些事，因为我之前错过了。所以，对此还有另一个术语。叫做“发展停滞”，不是指那部电视剧，虽然那真是一部精彩绝伦的电视剧，
but the term really refers to young adults, people in their 20s, who are mentally stuck at a younger emotional age than their chronological age and are not developing mentally at the expected rate because of normally it's trauma or some kind of really intense stressor. In this case, that stressor, that trauma was the pandemic. And so there is a stunted growth within young adults like you and me that maybe society doesn't recognize at large, but we definitely feel. Okay, so the second psychological reason for the pandemic skip, the pandemic took away our sense
但这个词实际上指的是年轻人，那些二十多岁的人，他们在心理上被困在一个比实际生理年龄更年轻的情感年龄，并且由于通常是创伤或某种非常强烈的压力源，导致他们没有以预期的速度在心理上成长。在这种情况下，那个压力源、那个创伤就是疫情。因此，像你我这样的年轻人内部存在着一种发育停滞，也许社会大众没有意识到，但我们绝对能感受到。好吧，关于“疫情跳过”的第二个心理学原因，是因为疫情剥夺了我们的
of agency and it made us feel powerless. We haven't gotten that back yet. Now, this matters a lot for people in their 20s. Having a sense of agency, feeling like you can direct your own life is really, really important to develop during this time. This period of our life is really the period where we flex that independence muscle. We flex that agency muscle. And that is represented by really big moments like moving out of home, solo traveling,
自主权，让我们感到无能为力。我们到现在还没找回那种感觉。这对于二十多岁的人来说非常重要。拥有自主权，感觉自己能够主导自己的人生，在这一时期发展起来真的非常、非常重要。我们生命的这个阶段，确实是我们舒展独立肌肉的时期。我们舒展自主权肌肉。而这体现在一些真正重大的时刻，比如搬出家门、独自旅行、
earning your own money, dating freely. The pandemic limited all of those activities. It limited all of our choices. It made us more dependent on our parents. and we also just, you know, as a result of the lockdowns and of wanting to be safe, we felt very caged and very locked away. And very much like our freedom, the freedom that was promised to us during this decade was something that was taken from us.
赚取自己的钱、自由地约会。疫情限制了所有这些活动。它限制了我们所有的选择。它让我们更加依赖父母。而且我们也只是因为封锁以及想要保持安全的愿望，感到自己被严重禁锢、严重锁起来了。很大程度上就像我们的自由，在这个十年里向我们承诺的自由，被从我们身边夺走了。
Now this diminished sense of agency and freedom against circumstances beyond our control, specifically circumstances that are unpleasant or frustrating, it can create a psychological state known as learned helplessness. Now, we've spoken about this before on the podcast, but learned helplessness is essentially a state we get into where we feel like no matter what, we cannot change our circumstances. We cannot change our fate. Any bad thing that happens to us is a given. We cannot escape that. and even to some extent anything we want from life,
现在，这种在超出我们控制范围的环境面前——特别是那些令人不快或沮丧的环境——而减弱的自主权和自由感，会产生一种被称为“习得性无助”的心理状态。我们在播客中以前也讨论过这一点，但习得性无助本质上是我们陷入的一种状态，在这种状态下，我们觉得无论如何，我们都无法改变自己的环境。我们无法改变自己的命运。发生在我们身上的任何坏事都是注定的。我们无法逃脱。甚至在某种程度上，我们从生活中想要的一切，
no matter how we work for it, we aren't going to get it because it's only fate and destiny that allows it. This makes us incredibly pessimistic because we get into the mind frame of why even try, like why would I even bother? This could be taken away at any moment. And we start thinking about, you know, how free am I really as a human?
无论我们如何为之努力，我们都无法得到它，因为只有运气和命运才允许这一切发生。这让我们变得极其悲观，因为我们陷入了一种思维框架：为什么还要尝试，我为什么还要白费力气？这一切随时都可能被夺走。我们开始思考，作为一个人，我到底有多自由？
How free am I really as a soul? you can kind of see the spiral that can very quickly get us into. A 2023 study found that COVID had a particularly profound impact on how in control we felt over our lives, and it's led to, as a result, very naturally higher levels of uncertainty, vulnerability, and self-consciousness when it comes to making decisions. Finally, the final explanation for the pandemic skip comes down to this long-term grief that a lot of us are experiencing.
作为一个灵魂，我到底有多自由？你可以想象，这会很快让我们陷入一种螺旋式下坠。2023 年的一项研究发现，新冠对我们对生活掌控感的感知产生了特别深远的影响，其结果自然而然地导致了在做决定时更高程度的不确定性、脆弱性和自我意识。最后，关于“疫情跳过”的最终解释，归结为我们许多人正在经历的这种长期悲伤。
Now grief, we know this. It comes in many, many forms. A lot of us, unfortunately, did actually lose people during the pandemic. I'm one of those people. I lost my granddad during COVID. And because of the way that lockdowns and border control was happening in Australia, I actually, I didn't get to say goodbye. I didn't get to go to the funeral.
悲伤，我们都知道这一点。它有多种多样的形式。不幸的是，我们许多人确实在疫情期间失去了亲人。我是其中之一。我在新冠期间失去了爷爷。由于澳大利亚当时实施的封锁和边境管制，实际上，我甚至没能跟他说声再见。我没能去参加葬礼。
I went to the funeral over Zoom, which was just, it's still to this day, so surreal. And I didn't really have a support network at the time. I wasn't living in the same state as my family. And so here I was completely alone in like my college room, not even my college room. It's like my sharehouse room having to mourn someone. And that still hurts. It still really hurts that I didn't get to say goodbye. And I felt like my grief was really, really.
我通过 Zoom 参加了葬礼，那种感觉直到今天依然是那么的超现实。当时我身边真的没有什么支持网络。我没有和家人住在同一个州。因此，我孤零零地一个人呆在大学宿舍里，甚至都不是大学宿舍，就像是在我合租房的房间里，不得不为一个人的离去而哀悼。这依然很痛。没能说声再见，这至今仍然让我感到非常痛苦。而且我感觉我的悲伤真的非常、非常
stagnant. I don't know. I just felt like I felt guilty for not being able to mourn quick enough because I just felt so detached from what it actually happened. And I will say like this is a common experience. And you can say I know that lockdowns were vital. I know that all those health measures were incredibly important. I get that. But still, it did hurt me emotionally and there were things that I missed out on that have had a lifelong impact on me. You can believe, both of those things at once and you can feel sad for the version of you that did really, really miss out. It's this idea actually of disenfranchised grief. Grief that society might not really understand that well, might not be quick to accept, might not think is appropriate, but if you're
停滞不前。我不知道。我只是觉得自己因为没能足够快地哀悼而感到内疚，因为我感觉自己与实际发生的事情太脱节了。我得说，这是一种很普遍的体验。你可以说，我知道封锁是至关重要的。我知道所有这些健康措施都极其重要。我懂的。但即便如此，它确实在情感上伤害了我，有些我错过的东西对我的整个人生都产生了影响。你可以同时相信这两件事，并且为那个真正、真正错过了很多东西的你自己感到难过。实际上，这就是“剥夺权利的悲伤”的概念。社会可能并不太理解这种悲伤，可能不会很快接受，可能不认为它是恰当的，但如果你
feeling it, it is appropriate. Just because your grief isn't about the death of a loved one, it's about the loss of an experience, loss of a potential experience that you were promised. That is still painful. You can still grieve the things you missed out on at a really formative juncture in your life. And let's think about what we did miss out on. Firstly, the big one, we missed out on travel. You may have missed out on exchanges. You missed out on in-person graduations.
感受到了，它就是恰当的。仅仅因为你的悲伤不是关于挚爱的离世，而是关于某种经历的失去，失去了你在人生中被承诺过的潜在体验。那依然是痛苦的。你仍然可以为你人生中一个至关重要的转折点上错过的东西感到悲伤。让我们想想我们都错过了什么。首先，最重大的一个是，我们错过了旅行。你可能错过了交流生项目。你错过了线下毕业典礼。
You may have missed out on moving out. You missed out on job opportunities. You missed out on dating. You missed out on making friends. You missed out on just being able to be outdoors and socialize and build community. And to be honest, at the most simple, simple form of this, you missed out on the potential to make memories you may not have even known you were going to make. The spontaneous kinds of memories.
你可能错过了搬出去住的机会。你错过了工作机会。你错过了约会。你错过了结交朋友。你错过了去户外活动、社交和建立社群的机会。老实说，用最简单、最简单的话来概括，你错过了创造那些你甚至可能不知道自己会创造的记忆的潜力。那种自发的记忆。
I think we missed out primarily in three distinct ways. We've missed out on experiences, so the fun stuff, the dating, the travel. We also missed out on the loss of connection. And we know that loneliness can be as deadly and dangerous as smoking 10 cigarettes a day. So what's the long-term health consequence going to be of being isolated for two to three years and only connecting with people through Netflix watch party and Zoom and TikTok? Like that's the first thing we really missed out on. We missed out on milestones.
我认为我们主要错过了三个不同方面。我们错过了经历，也就是好玩的事，约会、旅行。我们还错过了连接的失去。我们知道，孤独可以和一天吸 10 支烟一样致命和危险。那么，被孤立两到三年，且只能通过 Netflix 观影派对、Zoom 和 TikTok 与人连接，其长期的健康后果会是什么？就像那是我们真正错过的第一件事。我们错过了里程碑。
So the graduations, the academic opportunities, the professional opportunities, the 21st birthday parties, the 30th birthday parties, the 18th birthday parties, the anniversaries, all those kinds of things. One report from 2021 actually found that the number of non-employed college graduates went up by almost 20% during that time. A lot of us haven't been able to come back from that. And we still feel like, okay, so I'm, what, 25, 26 now going for the same jobs that people who are 22 and 21 are going for.
所以毕业典礼、学术机会、职业机会、21 岁生日派对、30 岁生日派对、18 岁生日派对、各种纪念日，所有这些类似的事情。2021 年的一份报告实际上发现，在此期间，失业大学毕业生的数量增加了近 20%。我们许多人一直没能从那个打击中恢复过来。我们仍然觉得，好吧，那我今年多少岁？25、26 岁了，还要去和那些 22 岁、21 岁的人竞争同一份工作。
And I feel like I'm behind. I feel like I'm behind because I couldn't do anything during this period. One final thing that we missed out on, and it's not so much that we missed out, but we, we stayed. We stayed in situations that we didn't want to be in. Let me explain this a little bit more. I was talking to a friend about this the other day who was dating someone during COVID, and she said to me, you know, if COVID hadn't have happened, I would have broken up with him.
我觉得自己落后了。我觉得自己落后了，因为在这期间我什么也做不了。最后一件我们错过的事情，与其说是错过，不如说是我们，我们留下了。我们留在了自己并不想呆的环境里。让我对此再多解释一点。前几天我和一个朋友聊起这个，她在新冠期间和某人约会，她对我说，你知道，如果新冠没有发生，我早就和他分手了。
And yet, I stayed in this relationship for another two to three years, I think another two years, because of the fact that we were living together and because of the fact that I needed him. This was my support network. I couldn't leave him during this time. and now I'm 29. She's almost 30 and she's like, well, I feel like I got to have my like fun little floaty period, but now I'm 30, but I feel like I'm 27. I feel like I'm ready to settle down, but I almost feel like I've missed the boat.
然而，这段恋爱我又维持了两到三年，我想是又维持了两年，原因是我们住在一起，而且因为我需要他。这是我的支持网络。在这期间我没法离开他。而现在我都 29 岁了。她快 30 岁了，她说，嗯，我觉得我本该有一段属于自己的、好玩又轻松的时期，但现在我都 30 岁了，可我感觉自己只有 27 岁。我觉得自己准备好安定下来了，但我几乎觉得自己错过了这班船。
I've missed the boat because I wanted to go about this in my own time, take my own timeline. And it was actually a really profound conversation where she was like, if COVID hadn't have happened, And maybe I'd be married now because I would have broken up with that person three years earlier. I would have done my fun dating period three years earlier. I would have met the love of my life three years earlier. So it's very complex and I think that that is a situation that a lot of us can really relate to. So what is the outcome of this? What is the outcome of this disenfranchised grief?
我错过了这班船，因为我想按照自己的节奏、自己的时间表来处理这件事。这其实是一次非常深刻的对话，她说：如果新冠没有发生，也许我现在已经结婚了，因为我会提前三年跟那个人分手。我会提前三年度过我快乐的约会期。我会提前三年遇到我一生的挚爱。所以这是非常复杂的，我认为这是我们许多人都能真正感同身受的一种情况。那么，这一切的结果是什么？这种被剥夺权利的悲伤结果是什么？
This warped sense of time, this sense of regret, resentment. I think firstly, we get really stuck in our... brains, we get really stuck in this thought spiral of this is so unfair. You know what it is unfair, but we feel resentful and upset and that lingers and we have no one to blame. And so we end up just feeling really sad. And eventually we can become really depressed about it, really depressed about the fact that there is this thing we can't change. If we linger on it for too long, it takes over our life. We also experience a sense of displacement, you know, this fractured reality. Like I should be in two places
这种扭曲的时间感，这种遗憾、怨恨、愤慨的感觉。我认为首先，我们的大脑陷入了死胡同，我们真正陷入了一种思维螺旋：这太不公平了。你知道这确实不公平，但我们感到怨恨、沮丧，这种情绪挥之不去，而且我们无处宣泄。因此，我们最终只会感到非常难过。最终，我们可能会对此感到非常沮丧，对这种无法改变的事情感到深深的沮丧。如果我们纠结太久，它就会接管我们的生活。我们还会经历一种失落感，你知道，这种破碎的现实。就像我本应该身处两个地方
at once. I should be here, but I'm here. I can't really tell what happened these last few years. There's this big chunk of time where I just feel like who even was I? There's a rise in catch-up mentality. I have to do the next three, four years of my life at two-time speed. We also forget how huge this thing was. It was a massive thing we went through. And what we end up doing is we project a sense of personal failure for feeling behind, not realizing that the entire world through, you know, went through this with us. We are not the only ones who are behind. And when we feel this way, it can be incredibly isolating and incredibly damaging for our self-esteem and our self-concept. So this brings me to the skip part. We see.
同时。我本该在这里，但我却在那里。我真的说不清过去这几年到底发生了什么。有一大段空白时间，我甚至觉得“我”到底是谁。追赶心态正在抬头。我必须以二倍速度过我生命的接下来三四年。我们还忘记了这件事有多么巨大。我们经历的是一件非常巨大的事情。而我们最终做的是，为自己感觉落后而产生一种个人失败感，却没有意识到全世界都和我们一起经历了这一切。我们并不是唯一落后的人。当我们有这种感觉时，它会让人感到非常孤立，并且对我们的自尊和自我概念造成极大的损害。这就把我带回了“跳过”这个部分。我们
skipped some of our 20s important periods of our life because of the pandemic. We didn't have proper time to live our 20s actively and richly and fill it with the experiences that we wanted. That cannot define us for the rest of this decade, nor for the rest of our life. So how do we ensure that we can still make the most of this precious time and let go of any indignation or grief or sadness that continues to linger? We're going to talk about all of that and so much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
因为疫情，跳过了二十多岁中一些重要的生命时期。我们没有合适的时间去积极、丰富地度过二十多岁的时光，并用我们想要的经历填满它。这不能定义我们这个十年的余下时间，也不能定义我们生命的余下时间。那么，我们如何确保自己依然能够充分利用这段宝贵的时光，并放下任何继续挥之不去的愤慨、悲伤或难过呢？在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。《2%》。这就是当电梯旁有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J.
收听《2%》。名称是 T-W-O-P-P-Cent，请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈 80 年代的快克。澄清一下，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在节目里聊快克，但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，到了这个时候，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的线索了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on that. iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首当年》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
欢迎收听我的新播客《难走的路》，我是主持人、也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
那是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你真正地去做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《难走的路》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023 年，前《钻石单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini.
这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你曾把这份特定的测试结果篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试结果。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
podcasts. When we feel deep resentment, bitterness, indignation towards a situation, that can really infect our mind and make it such that we see the world differently. We gain an entirely new perspective on how unfair the world is, how awful life is, it can also just lead us to become quite obsessive and continually focused on everything that isn't working out for us rather than the things that are. You know, that unfairness that we've all experienced, it's quite a toxic feeling and it's one that, you know, sometimes our brain finds quite a satisfying and enjoyable to self-pity and to say, God, that was so unfair and this is so awful. I think there is a time and a place for that.
当我们对一种情况感到深深的怨恨、苦涩、愤慨时，这真的会感染我们的思维，让我们以不同的方式看待世界。我们对世界有多么不公平、生活有多么糟糕获得了一种全新视角，这也可能导致我们变得相当强迫性，并持续专注于所有对我们不利的事情，而不是那些进展顺利的事情。你知道，我们都经历过的那种不公平，是一种相当有毒的感觉，而且有时我们的大脑会发现，通过自我怜悯以及说“天哪，那太不公平了，这太糟糕了”来获得一种相当满足和享受的感觉。我认为有其时间和地点。
There is a time and a place to acknowledge that the pandemic really sucked and has left long-term impacts, but there is a stage where you have to realize that you can either let go or be dragged. You can either let your thoughts about how unfair the pandemic was continue to infiltrate the next five years of your life. or you can find a way to live with it. And I think the healthiest kinds of people psychologically and emotionally and mentally, it's not that bad things don't happen to them.
确实需要时间和地点来承认新冠疫情真的很糟糕，并留下了长期的影响，但在某个阶段，你必须意识到：要么放下，要么被拖着走。要么让关于疫情有多么不公平的想法继续渗透你未来五年的生活，要么就找到一种与它共存的方法。我认为，在心理、情感和精神上最健康的那些人，并不是说坏事不会降临到他们头上。
It's that they understand how to hold complex emotions at the same time. They understand how to still be excited and happy and also nostalgic and sad. It's definitely a fine line between honoring your emotional. emotions and also not allowing them to pull you down. But I think the really important attitude to adopt is one of a stoic. Adopt some of the principles of stoicism. And stoicism is this important philosophy around acknowledging and observing your circumstances and the bad things that have happened to you and not letting them influence you deeper than you would like them to. So it's basically about being a ship in a really big storm, riding the waves, riding with the rocking of the ship, knowing that there are some
而是他们懂得如何在同一时间内保持复杂的情感。他们懂得如何依然感到兴奋、快乐，同时也怀旧、悲伤。在尊重你的情绪和不让情绪把你往下拽之间，绝对有一条微妙的界限。但我认为真正需要采纳的重要态度是斯多葛学派的态度。采纳斯多葛主义的一些原则。斯多葛主义是一种重要的哲学，围绕着承认和观察你的环境以及发生在你身上的坏事，而不让它们对你的影响超过你所希望的程度。所以它基本上就是做暴风雨中的一艘船，乘风破浪，随着船体的摇晃而起伏，深知有些
things you cannot change, but you can endure them, and you can't, you can come out the other side if you don't invest too much emotionally in them. If you don't invest too much in your sense of injustice or unfairness. In terms of recovering from the sense that you've missed out, I think some of the best tips that I found have actually come from people who have experienced chronic illness. So people who have found themselves, you know, trapped in a body, trapped in a life, struggling with a condition that is meant that they can't do all the things that are sold to them as the glamorous parts, the romantic parts of being in your 20s. So they've had some kind of major health setback. They have been inside for six months because of illness. They've been in hospitals
事情是你无法改变的，但你可以忍受它们，而且如果你不在情感上投入过多，你是可以从另一端走出来的。如果你不过分投入到你的不公感或不公平感中。在从那种“错失感”中恢复过来方面，我认为我发现的一些最好的建议实际上来自于那些经历过慢性疾病的人。也就是那些发现自己被困在身体里、被困在生活中、与某种疾病抗争的人，这种疾病意味着他们无法做所有那些被兜售为二十多岁时迷人、浪漫部分的那些事情。所以他们经历了一些重大健康挫折。由于生病，他们在室内呆了六个月。当其他人出去派对时，他们呆在医院里。
when other people have been out partying. They've been exhausted when other people have been out dating. a lot of people with chronic illness actually do have remarkable tips for those of us struggling with pandemic skip. And so I actually asked some people, I said, you know, from your learnings, what is, what would you wish other people would know? What do you wish, what do you think would help other people? Some of the tips people gave me were to manage and prioritize quality over quantity. So really create a list and be. quite particular about what experiences are really important to you. What are the big experiences that you really do feel like you missed out on?
当其他人出去约会时，他们精疲力竭。许多慢性疾病患者实际上为我们这些与“疫情跳过”作斗争的人提供了非凡的建议。所以我实际上问了一些人，我说，从你们的经验教训中，你希望其他人知道什么？你希望、你认为什么能帮助到其他人？人们给我的部分建议是：管理并优先考虑质量而非数量。所以真正列一个清单，并且。对哪些经历对你真正重要要非常挑剔。哪些是你真正觉得错过了的重大经历？
How can you prioritize them with the time that you do have, with the resources that you do have? Some other tips was don't compare your timeline to others. Of course, so powerful. Anytime you find your thoughts, your eyes, your attitude, straying and clasping onto someone else's life and saying that's evidence that my life isn't good enough please direct it back inwards try and find something about your life small things that you are grateful for and that you are joyful for a try not to ruminate on the past was another one and i loved this one in particular this one i actually found online and it was to be spontaneous with your good days so when you know
如何用你拥有的时间、用你拥有的资源优先处理它们？其他一些建议是：不要将你的时间线与他人进行比较。当然，这非常有力量。每当发现你的思想、你的目光、你的态度偏离并攀附上别人的生活，并以此证明我的生活还不够好时，请把它引导回内心的方向，试着在你的生活中寻找一些你所感激、所快乐的小事，试着不要对过去耿耿于怀是另一个建议，我特别喜欢这个建议。这个建议其实是我在网上看到的，那就是：在状态好的日子里要顺其自然、随性而为。所以当你知道
you've got a day off when you're feeling amazing, when everything is working out, take advantage of it. Don't do the things that you need to do. You know, don't say, oh, it's a beautiful Sunday, but I have to do my chores. Embrace the spontaneity and the opportunity of good days, of free time, of the time that you do have. So I love those tips. I think they're wonderful. We can learn from the experience of so many other people. I do have some of my own. And my first in that same line of stoic philosophy is to really come to terms with and accept the fact that you cannot make up for that time. And I know that's scary and I know that's upsetting. But please take, I don't know, take what you need from this.
你有一天假期，当你感觉棒极了，当一切都很顺利时，好好利用它。不要去做那些你“需要”做的事。你知道，不要说“哦，今天是个美好的星期天，但我必须做家务”。拥抱好日子、自由时间以及你所拥有的时间的随性和机遇。所以我很喜欢这些建议。我认为它们棒极了。我们可以从许多其他人的经历中学习。我确实也有我自己的建议。我的第一条建议，本着同样的斯多葛哲学，就是真正去面对并接受这样一个事实：你无法弥补那段时间。我知道这很可怕，我知道这让人心烦意乱。但请接受，我不知道，从中学取你需要的东西吧。
Take what you need from the fact that you weren't the only one and you weren't the only person who lost it. So this is something that's always very comforting for me is no one. is knowing that anything I've been through I did not experience in isolation. Someone else has gone through this. Someone else is probably also feeling just as behind and confused as you. In fact, I can give you evidence for that. I have thousands of DMs to prove that a lot of us are struggling with this. The thing is, yes, nothing I say is going to give you back that time.
从你不是唯一一个失控的人、也不是唯一一个崩溃的人这一事实中，去寻找你需要的东西吧。所以，这总让我感到非常欣慰，那就是没有人——那就是我知道我经历过的任何事情都不是孤立的。别人也经历过。别人可能也和你一样感到落后和迷茫。事实上，我可以给你证据。我有成千上万条私信可以证明，我们当中有很多人都在为此苦苦挣扎。问题是，是的，我说什么也无法把那些时间还给你。
But I can tell you how to use the time you do have better. I think that you need to take a gap year now. who cares if you're 27 if you're 28 it's better to take a gap year now than 48 you know the urge is still going to be there what is holding you back it might be that you don't want to disappoint people you want to stay ahead in terms of your career goals you want to stay on track who cares like genuinely who cares it's a career it's a profession it's a job that's not the entire point of your life The point of your life is to make good memories and actually enjoy your experiences and to just be alive. So if you want to take a gap year now, honestly, who cares what anyone else thinks?
但我可以告诉你如何更好地利用你现在拥有的时间。我觉得你现在需要过一个间隔年（gap year）。如果你27岁、28岁，谁在乎呢？现在过一个间隔年，总比48岁再过要好，你知道那种冲动依然会存在。是什么在阻挡你？可能是你不想让人失望，你想在职业目标上保持领先，你想按部就班。谁在乎呢？真心话，谁在乎呢？这只是一份事业、一个行业、一份工作，它并不是你生活的全部。你人生的意义在于创造美好的回忆，真正享受你的经历，并且好好活着。所以，如果你现在想过一个间隔年，老实说，谁在乎别人怎么想呢？
Who cares if it's not the right time? Who cares if you're too old? Like, genuinely, the people who might say that to you, gosh, how miserable are they? How miserable are they to never accept when we go off the book or we go off the timeline and we just have to give up on those experiences that were promised to us at a certain period. You don't want to be like them. You want to be like you. So take the gap here now. Do the things you wanted to do back then. Now, I would also say create a bucket list. So all those things that you really thought you were going to get done between 2020 and 2022, 2023, make a bucket list now of the things you really want to do, things you really want to see in the next two years and actually can.
谁在乎现在是不是好时机？谁在乎你是不是年纪太大了？说真的，那些可能会对你这么说的人，天哪，他们该有多痛苦啊？他们怎么能如此无法接受我们打破常规或偏离时间表，而不得不放弃那些在特定时期承诺给我们的经历呢？你可不想变成他们那样。你想成为你自己。所以，现在就去过间隔年吧。去做你当时想做的事。现在，我还要建议你列一个愿望清单（bucket list）。所以，把你所有那些你以为在2020年到2022年、2023年之间一定能完成的事情，现在就列一个愿望清单，写下你在接下来的两年里真正想做的事、真正想看的事，并且真正去落实。
commit to ticking them off. Like make a visual or make a something tangible of what it really is that you felt you missed out on. See if you can bring those into your life now. Make it a priority, make it a goal to get those things done. I also think that it's important that we all sit down for a second and rethink the goals that you set for your 20s before the pandemic happened. I am guilty of this. I set a lot of goals for myself and I came out of. I came out of the of the pandemic expecting me to still be able to complete them in the timeline that I had given myself at 19 and 20. And the thing is, is that that was no longer possible. There was a huge spanner in the works. There was a huge barrier to completion. That doesn't mean I failed. People
承诺把它们一一勾掉。比如，把那些你觉得错过了的真正遗憾，做成视觉化的东西或是有形的东西。看看你现在能不能把它们带进你的生活里。把这些事情当成首要任务、当作一个目标去完成。我还认为，我们所有人都应该花点时间坐下来，重新思考你在大流行发生之前为20s（20多岁）设定的目标。我也有过错。我为自己设定了很多目标，然后我走出了——我走出了大流行的阴影，却依然期望自己能在19岁和20岁时给自己的时间表内完成它们。问题是，这已经不再可能了。计划中杀出了一个巨大的程咬金。完成目标出现了一个巨大的障碍。但这并不意味着我失败了。人们
face setbacks all the time. It just meant that I needed to adjust my goals a little bit to make up for just this extraneous external thing that came in and kind of ruined the day. So if you're feeling the pressure of the catch-up mentality, you're feeling behind, I would really ask you, do your goals need revising based on what has occurred? Do they need to be modified a little bit? There's no shame in that. They're your goals. It's not like anyone else has a list. It's not like anyone else knows what they are. They're your goals. You can complete them in your own time. And I also want you to remember, timelines are literally fake. There is no universal timeline. In fact, I can promise you, I promise you, I'm going to put a hundred bucks on the table right now. You can get a hundred,
总是会遇到挫折。这只是意味着我需要稍微调整一下我的目标，来弥补这个突然出现、把计划搞砸的外部突发事件。所以，如果你正感受到追赶同龄人的心理压力，觉得落后了，我真的想问你：根据已经发生的事情，你的目标需要修改吗？它们需要稍微调整一下吗？这没什么好丢脸的。这是你的目标。又不是别人也有一份清单。又不是别人知道它们是什么。这是你的目标。你可以按自己的节奏完成它们。我还想让你记住，时间表这东西纯粹是虚构的。根本没有一个普适的时间表。事实上，我向你保证，我向你保证，我马上拿一百块钱出来打赌。你可以找一百个
20-something year olds. If you can find two people with the same timeline, I will literally give you $100. Like, it, to the, it's just impossible. It's literally just impossible. everybody is doing things differently. They're starting uni at different ages. They're graduating at different ages. They're taking different internships, jobs. They're doing trades. They're not going to uni.
二十多岁的人。如果你能找到两个时间表完全相同的人，我literally（简直）给你100美元。这，简直，这根本是不可能的。这纯粹是不可能的。每个人做事情的方式都不同。他们上大学的年龄不同。他们毕业的年龄不同。他们做不同的实习、工作。他们去学手艺。他们不上大学。
They're, you know, pausing studies, going part-time for a little bit, going back to full-time. Like, every single person has a unique path through life. I really want you to ask yourself, the grand perfect timeline. Who set that up? And who do you know that's actually meeting it? and are they happier than you? Are they happier than you?
他们呢，你知道的，暂停学业，做一阵子兼职，然后再回去读全职。每一个人的生活轨迹都是独一无二的。我真的很想问问你，那个宏大而完美的时间表——是谁定下来的？你认识的人里又有谁真正达到了？他们比你快乐吗？他们比你快乐吗？
You don't know. And can you promise me that you would be just as happy as them if you did it the way they did it? Answer is probably not, because you have your own unique preferences, you have your own unique desires for what you want to do with these 10 years. I also think it's totally okay to feel like you can tap a few extra years onto the end part of your 20s and keep calling yourself 29 if you really want to and continue to feel like you're making, and continue to really be selfish and to be, I don't know, possessive with the time that you want to take to experience the things that you wanted to experience in your 20s.
你不知道。你能向我保证，如果你按照他们的做法去做，你就会和他们一样快乐吗？答案很可能是否定的，因为你有自己独特的偏好，对于在这十年里你想做的事情，你有自己独特的愿望。我也觉得，在20多岁的尾巴上给自己偷偷加上好几年，如果你真的很想的话，继续管自己叫29岁，这完全没问题；并且继续觉得自己正在取得成就，继续保持那种自私的态度，或者说，我不知道，对你想要花时间去体验那些你在20多岁时想要体验的事情有一种“占有欲”，这都是完全可以的。
I'm also going to say this, don't forget to pause. Don't forget to just enjoy the moment you're in now as well instead of trying to, relive and make up for lost time. This period is just as important as the periods that have come before this. Focus on, you know, all the depths of experiences that you're having right now. Really sink into the moments that you are having right now. How important it is to be here and the fact that, you know, things have maybe worked out not in the way that you wanted them to, but how do you know it would have been any better? If there is just a couple of things that you were grateful for that you have in your life at this instance, know that you may not have had them
我还要说的是：别忘了停下脚步。不要一味地试图去重温和弥补失去的时间，也别忘了去享受你现在的这一刻。这段时期和之前经历的时期同样重要。专注于，你知道的，你现在正在经历的所有丰富深刻的体验。真正沉浸在此时此刻的 moments（时刻）里。身处此地是多么重要，而且事实上，你知道的，事情的走向或许并非如你所愿，但你怎么知道它本来会变得更好呢？如果在此时此刻，你的生活中仅仅有那么几件让你心怀感激的事情，你要知道，你可能根本不会拥有它们——
if the pandemic hadn't have happened. It's not me trying to be all toxic positivity on you. You guys know I hate that. It's more that I just want you to make sure you have a balance between, yeah, feeling a little bit upset about it every now and again and also appreciating the present moment so that you're not constantly in like a delayed, not delayed, like, like a delayed happiness cycle. Like I can only feel happy about that moment in three years time or I'm constantly trying to catch up. I'm never going to feel at that point again.
如果大流行没有发生的话。我可不是在这里对你进行什么“毒鸡汤式的积极”（toxic positivity）。你们都知道我讨厌那样。我更希望确保你能在两者之间找到平衡：一方面，偶尔为之感到有点沮丧；另一方面，也能感激当下的时刻，这样你就不会总是陷入那种延迟的、不能算延迟，就像是那种“延迟快乐”的循环中。就好像“我只能在三年后才能对那个时刻感到快乐”，或者“我一直在拼命追赶，我永远不会再有那种感觉了”。
At some point you really just have to say, okay, it happened, but I'm here right now and I don't want to miss out on this moment. So that's really how I've thought about it. I hope you can relate to it as well, but that's my best kind of pieces of advice for dealing with this like what is a very very very strange emotional experience one that we will probably never go through again now let's have some like let's have a bit of grace and pause for
在某个时刻，你真的只能说：好吧，事情已经发生了，但我现在就在这里，我不想错过这一刻。所以这真的是我对此的思考方式。我希望你也能感同身受，但这是我对于如何应对这种非常、非常、非常奇怪的情感体验——一种我们可能永远不会再经历的体验——所能给出的最好的建议。现在，让我们对自己多一点宽容，并为之停下脚步，
that like it was traumatic we're never going to hopefully go through something like that again so now you can really get to living you can exit survival mode you don't have to be hypervigilant and you can start making up for those experiences by prioritizing the quality, really beautiful experiences that you always wanted to have and having them now. All right, I think it's time that we turn to our listener questions because you guys flooded my DMs with so many brilliant, brilliant questions that you wanted answered. So we're going to take a quick pause, but we will return shortly. So stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also a
就好像——这确实是一场创伤，希望我们永远不会再经历那样的事情了。所以现在你真的可以开始生活了，你可以退出生存模式了，你不需要时刻保持高度警惕了，你可以通过优先考虑那些你一直渴望拥有的、高质量的、真正美好的体验，并把它们变成现实，来开始弥补那些失去的经历。好了，我觉得是时候转向我们的听众提问了，因为你们的私信塞满了太多精彩绝伦、你想得到解答的问题。所以我们要短暂暂停一下，但很快就会回来。请锁定频道。2%。这就是当有
and escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能以及建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It Podcast. I'm Sam J.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）莉儿·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何熬过这段日子的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）探讨80年代古柯碱（crack）的节目。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为古柯碱。我随时准备聊聊古柯碱，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这已经是我们第二集讨论古柯碱了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。
And in recognition of mental health awareness, this month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
为了响应心理健康意识月，本月我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear. here on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free,
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这里做一个好人很重要？在这个地球上？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的
our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family, court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
IHeart Radio App，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So this is a new thing that we are trying out on the podcast where for each topic that I do, each solo episode, I do ask you guys to share your questions to share some of the things that you want answered. You know, I do my best to really cover as much as I can as much as the psychology and, you know,
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以这是我们在播客中尝试的一项新内容：对于我做的每一个主题、每一个单人独白节目，我都会请大家分享你们的问题，分享你们希望得到解答的事情。你知道的，我尽我所能去涵盖尽可能多的内容，涵盖尽可能多的心理学，以及，你知道的，
some of the science and the ideas behind these topics. But sometimes you guys just have such brilliant ideas and brilliant questions about things that are quite niche or are quite specific. So this is what this little section is for. Make sure you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. Two weeks before an episode goes live, I do put out the polls slash question boxes to get your questions on the topics that are coming up in the future. So stay tuned for those.
这些主题背后的部分科学和理念。但有时你们总会有如此精彩的想法和精彩的问题，关于那些相当小众或非常具体的事情。所以这就是这个小板块的用途。确保你在Instagram上关注我：@that psychology podcast。在节目上线前两周，我会发布投票/问题征集框，来收集你们对未来即将推出的主题的提问。所以请持续关注。
Let's talk about this first question. This first question says, is it valid to identify with a younger age because of pandemic skip? Yeah, absolutely. I have this ongoing joke with all my friends that I'm still 22 because I still feel 22. Like if, I don't know, I don't think it's bad to just like have a little joke about it, but also to just seriously be like, okay, I'm, I can tell myself what I want to feel. Like, if it's going to make you feel better about the pandemic and what you may have missed out on, saying to yourself, okay, yes, I am 21 now. I'm still 21. I'm still 22. I'm still 23. And I'm going to. live my life as if I actually am this age. If that works for you, please, please go for it. I think that's fine. I'm sure someone's going to say, you know, oh, but that's going to create
我们来聊聊第一个问题。这第一个问题是：因为大流行错失的几年而认同更年轻的年龄，这合理吗？是的，绝对合理。我和我所有的朋友都有这样一个常开的玩笑，说我还是22岁，因为我感觉自己依然是22岁。如果，我不知道，我觉得开个小玩笑无伤大雅，但也可以认真地想：好吧，我，我可以告诉我自己我想感受到什么。如果这能让你对大流行以及你可能错过的事情感觉好一点，对自己说：“好吧，是的，我现在21岁。我还是21岁。我还是22岁。我还是23岁。”并且我要像自己真的是这个年龄一样去生活。如果这管用，求求你了，请尽管去尝试吧。我觉得这没问题。我敢肯定有人会说：“你知道的，哦，但这会产生
this complex relationship with aging and it might make us stunted. I think that if that's going to be a problem, you can fix it when you get to it. For now, if this is your biggest issue and the biggest source of mental distress is feeling younger than you actually are and feeling like you've missed out, you can literally just tell yourself you're younger than you actually are. I give you permission. So this is the next question that I received. I really like this question. Should I feel guilty for desiring that unstructured free time again?
一种复杂的衰老关系，可能会阻碍我们成长。”我认为，如果那会成为一个问题，等你遇到了再去解决它吧。现在，如果这是你最大的问题，你最大的精神痛苦来源是觉得自己比实际年龄小、觉得自己错过了很多，你完全可以告诉自己，你比实际年龄要小。我批准了。所以这是我收到的下一个问题。我真的很喜欢这个问题：对于重新渴望那种无结构、自由的时间，我应该感到内疚吗？
I miss being myself. Was this not one of the best parts of the pandemic? There was a lot of really awful stuff and a lot of really terrible experiences. But the free time that we had, that unstructured time, was incredible. Think about all the different like challenges we were doing. What was that like cream coffee that we were making? All the time we had to do arts and craft projects to deep clean our house, to read, to watch TV. It was just complete leisure. And of course, sometimes that became problematic because it got a little bit boring and it got a little bit toxic and felt yuck sometimes
我怀念做回自己。这难道不是大流行期间最棒的部分之一吗？当时有很多真的很糟糕的事情，也有很多极其痛苦的经历。但我们拥有的那些自由时间，那些无结构的时间，是不可思议的。想想我们做过的所有那些不同的挑战。我们当时做的那种泡沫咖啡是什么来着？我们有那么多时间做艺术品和手工艺品，大扫除，读书，看电视。那完全是休闲。当然，有时这会变成一个问题，因为它变得有点无聊，变得有点令人窒息，感觉有时候很糟糕，
because we've been doing it for so long. And maybe you did kind of miss the discipline at the time. but I do think that some element of what we were doing during the pandemic and all that free time is how we're meant to be living now. We are actually meant to have more free time. We are actually meant to have more unstructured time for creativity, for curiosity, for play, just for making things. So, no, I don't think you should feel guilty for it. I actually think it's entirely normal because there were parts of it that were actually quite good. I do understand also that your guilt is maybe referring to the fact that, you know,
因为我们已经这样过太久了。而且也许你当时确实有点怀念纪律感。但我确实认为，我们在大流行期间所做的事情的一些元素，以及所有那些自由时间，其实正是我们现在应该有的生活方式。我们实际上应该拥有更多自由时间。我们实际上应该拥有更多无结构的时间来发挥创造力、保持好奇心、玩耍，仅仅是去创造事物。所以，不，我觉得你不应该为此感到内疚。我实际上认为这完全正常，因为其中有些部分确实挺好的。我也理解，你的内疚可能指的是这样一个事实，即，你知道的，
people did lose their lives and people did get really sick. Maybe you feel bad for saying to people, I kind of enjoyed it. Just because there is an experience that someone else had doesn't mean that your experience is completely invalidated. And it doesn't mean that your experience doesn't also count for something. It's not saying that you are glad that that happened by no means. you're saying, in my little corner of the world, for what this did to me, I'm not entirely ungrateful for it.
人们确实失去了生命，人们确实病得很重。也许你对人们说“我其实挺享受的”会感到内疚。仅仅因为别人有过某种经历，并不意味着你的经历就被完全否定了。这并不意味着你的经历就没有价值。这并不是说你很高兴那种事情发生了，绝不是。你是在说：“在我世界的一小角，对于这件事对我的影响，我并非全无感激。”
So that's my answer to your question. This next question is something we've only loosely discussed. So I am really glad that someone asked this. What effect has the pandemic skip had on dating? Dating is one of the, I think one of the big challenges of our 20s and the things that we think about most, you know, thinking about love and am I going to meet the right person. It's something hugely on our minds. I think that the pandemic has made it harder. I'm not going to sugarcoat it. It's made it harder. People are less likely to commit, but we're at the age
所以这就是我对你问题的回答。接下来的这个问题是我们之前只是泛泛讨论过的内容。所以我很高兴有人问这个。大流行导致的“跳过”对约会产生了什么影响？约会是，我认为是我们20多岁时面临的重大挑战之一，也是我们考虑得最多的事情之一，你知道的，考虑到爱，我会遇到对的人吗？这是深深占据我们脑海的事情。我认为大流行让约会变得更难了。我不会粉饰太平。它确实变得更难了。人们更不愿意承诺了，但我们正处于这样一个年龄，
where society wants us to commit and it's mismatched, right? So again, you may be 27, 28, maybe 29, maybe in your 30s and you know there is this real pressure of like I haven't met anyone yet I haven't met anyone yet like oh I'm getting older I'm getting older which is a complete bullshit by the way it's just this whole societal game but you do feel that way and then there's this also other equally compelling sense of I want to take my time because I probably took a break from dating for a huge chunk a huge period and I still feel like I want to have the experiences of casual dating and getting to enjoy myself and meeting more people. And so the chapters don't align. There's these two versions of you who are battling it out for kind of what to do with your heart, I guess.
社会希望我们定下来，而这并不匹配，对吧？所以同样地，你可能27岁、28岁，也许29岁，也许30多岁，你知道这种真正的压力：“我还没遇到任何人，我还没遇到任何人，哦，我越来越老了，我越来越老了。”顺便说一句，这纯属放屁，这只是一种社会游戏，但你确实会有这种感觉。然后同时还有另一种同样引人注目的感觉：我想花点时间，因为我可能在很大一段时间、很长的时期里暂停了约会，我仍然觉得我想体验一下随意约会（casual dating）、享受乐趣以及结识更多人的经历。所以这两个篇章并不对齐。你体内有两个版本的声音在争夺，不知道该如何安放你的心，我猜是这样的。
And I think that can especially cause frustration when two people are dating or two people are, you know, courting each other who are in different, who are the same age, but in different phases. someone has experienced this pandemic pause, pandemic skip, the other person hasn't, the other person is pushing for commitment, and the first person is saying I'm not ready. It makes it very, very hard. I also think that it's probably created a little bit of social anxiety within us, you know, dating and socializing and making friends and connection. I truly believe that it's a skill and it's something that we build with practice and we get better at, especially during our 20s, but if, of course, you didn't get the opportunities to
我认为，当两个人正在约会，或者两个人正在，你知道的，互相追求，他们年龄相同，但却处于不同的人生阶段时，这尤其会引起挫折感。一个人经历了这次大流行的暂停、大流行的跳过，另一个人没有；另一个人在催促承诺，而第一个人则说我还没准备好。这使得一切变得非常、非常艰难。我也认为，这可能在我们内心创造了一点社交焦虑，你知道的，约会、社交、结交朋友和建立连接。我坚信这是一种技能，是我们通过实践不断培养的东西，我们会变得更好，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，但当然，如果你没有得到机会去
practice and to go on dates, you might be feeling a little bit rusty. I'll just say this. Love is not something you need to rush. It's also most certainly not something that you need to put a million rules on of when I should meet someone and how it should go and all these things. It will happen. Please find a way to make it as the most enjoyable and and fun that it can be for you. I did an episode recently on how to reclaim your power in dating. I think if you're struggling with that, that episode is exactly what you need to hear.
练习和约会，你可能会觉得有点生疏。我只想说：爱不是一件你需要去赶进度的事情。它也绝对不是一件你需要为之设定一百万条规则的事情，比如我应该在什么时候遇到某人、事情应该如何发展以及所有这些琐事。它会发生。请找到一种方法，让它对你来说尽可能地充满乐趣和享受。我最近做了一期关于如何在约会中夺回自主权的节目。我想如果你正在为此苦恼，那期节目正是你需要听的。
Okay, one final question. How do you come to terms with the fact that you missed out on the iconic chapter of your life? Now, I chose this question because we've really kind of already talked about this, but we haven't talked about this language, this language of the iconic chapter. I just want to, you know, maybe give you a bit of like hard love, but I think it's comforting.
好的，最后一个问题。你如何接受这样一个事实：你错过了人生中极具标志性的篇章？现在，我选择这个问题是因为我们其实已经讨论过这个了，但我们还没有讨论过这种表述，这种关于“标志性的篇章”的表述。我只是想，你知道的，也许给你一点“严厉的爱（hard love）”，但我认为这是令人宽慰的。
You actually haven't missed out on your iconic chapter. You haven't. You've only missed out on a couple of years. I think that it can feel like there's a lot more magnitude to it and it can feel a lot bigger because every single year within this period really counts, but you haven't even missed out on a third of it. Like you have so much more time on either side, to really push out those experiences.
你其实并没有错过你那标志性的篇章。你没有。你只是错过了几年而已。我觉得这可能会让人觉得分量更重，感觉规模更大，因为这段时期的每一年都真的至关重要，但你甚至连这十年的三分之一都没错过。就像在两头你还有更多的时间，去真正尽情体验那些经历。
I also think that as a collective, as a society, we need to be better at acknowledging that your 20s are probably not the best years of your life. Sure, they're iconic. You know, sex in the city only began when everyone in that TV show was 32. And that's such an iconic TV show of like exploration and fun and career success and love and heartbreak and glamour.
我也认为，作为一个集体、作为一个社会，我们需要更好地承认：你的20多岁可能并不是你一生中最美好的时光。当然，它们很有标志性。你知道的，《欲望都市》直到剧中的每个人都32岁时才开播。那是一部关于探索、乐趣、事业成功、爱情、心碎和魅力的极具标志性的电视剧。
I really think we need to get over this idea that you turn 30 and you're dead. Like your whole life is over and you've never going to have fun again. The people I know who are in their 30s are having a lot more fun than the people I know in their 20s. And they're hotter and they do it better and they have more money and they feel more secure and they're just having the best time. And again with this myth that you've missed out on an iconic chapter, I do get the grief and I feel like some of the other advice I've given can definitely help. with that but you know there was another study from 2018 and I talk about this study a lot that actually found that your 20s are not the best chapter the best decade. What we tend to think is the best decade in our
我真的觉得我们需要克服这种想法：觉得一旦你30岁了你就完蛋了。就像你的人生全完了，你再也不会快乐了。我认识的30多岁的人比我认识的20多岁的人过得要开心得多。而且他们更性感，他们把生活过得更好，他们有更多的钱，他们感到更有安全感，他们只是在过着最棒的生活。同样，关于“你错过了一个标志性篇章”这个神话，我确实理解这种悲伤，而且我觉得我之前给出的其他建议肯定能对此有所帮助。但你知道的，还有一项2018年的研究——我经常谈论这项研究——它实际上发现，你的20多岁并不是最好的篇章、最好的十年。我们往往认为生活中最好的十年，
lives is the one that we are currently in. So if you are in your 20s, of course you're thinking, oh my God, this is the best year of my, these are the best years of my life. In your 30s, you'll think the same, in your 40s, in your 50s, in your 60s. So appreciate make the most of the time you still have during this decade, but know that there are. is not a single experience during this decade that is confined or, you know, restricted by age. You can come back and do the things you missed out on at 70 if you really want. You have heaps and heaps of time. And that's really the sentiment that I want to finish the episode on.
其实是我们目前正身处其中的这十年。所以如果你正处于20多岁，你当然会想：“噢天哪，这是我人生中最棒的一年，这些是我人生中最美好的时光。”到了30多岁，你也会这么想，40多岁、50多岁、60多岁时也是如此。所以，请珍惜并充分利用你在这十年里还拥有的时间，但要知道，在这十年中，没有任何一种经历是被年龄所局限或限制的。如果你真的很想的话，你可以在70岁时回过头去做那些你错过的事情。你有大把大把的时间。这真的是我想在这集节目结束时传达的情感。
You have so much time, even if it feels like you've missed out. There's so much good stuff coming. The pandemic was awful. I'm glad we're out of it. But don't let it ruin your life. Don't let the remnants of that emotional traumatic experience to find the rest of the many, many, many brilliant years you have in front of you. Thank you so much for listening to this episode. If you have made it this far, I want you to, hmm, you know I love living an emoji at this point.
你还有那么多时间，即使你觉得好像错过了什么。有那么多美好的事物正在到来。大流行太可怕了。我很高兴我们走出来了。但别让它毁了你的生活。不要让那个充满情感创伤的经历的残余，去定义你面前那许许多多、无比精彩的未来岁月。非常感谢收听本集节目。如果你听到了这里，我想让你——嗯，你知道的，我此时此刻很喜欢发表情符号。
You can do like the virus emoji, maybe. Yeah, I feel like the virus emoji is cute in like a weirdly morbid way. I love knowing how many of you really listen all the way to the end. And you know, I love also hearing your questions, your feedback on this episode, anything that I haven't talked about that you think you could contribute. Drop it in the comments. Other people might agree. Maybe they won't. But it's just such a great way to see this conversation continue.
你可以发个病毒的表情符号，也许吧。是的，我觉得病毒的表情符号在一种奇怪的病态中显得很可爱。我喜欢知道你们当中有多少人真的把节目听到了最后。你知道的，我也喜欢听取你们的问题、你们对这集节目的反馈，以及任何我没有谈到、而你觉得可以贡献看法的想法。把它留在评论区吧。其他人可能会同意。也许不会。但这真的是见证这场对话延续下去的绝佳方式。
Make sure that you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. Obviously, you know, the book is coming out so, so soon. So if you don't want to miss updates, make sure you are following me there. and follow along wherever you're listening, leave a five-star review, only if you feel cool to do so, of course. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
确保你在Instagram上关注我：@that psychology podcast。显而易见，你知道的，书马上、马上就要出版了。所以如果你不想错过最新动态，确保你在那里关注我。无论你在哪里收听，也请关注节目，留下五星好评，当然，如果你觉得值得的话。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快、很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能以及建立韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个惯犯骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here,
在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格里ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何熬过这段日子的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代。那是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts收听《Look Back at It》，
or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
或者在任何你获取播客的地方收听。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可惹不起。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，
listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一档IHeart播客。人类品质保证。本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。